so i think just try and learn as much
you can try and be a sponge try and
think about the agency that you're in
what people are doing things really well
and then try and get time with those
people and just ask them
like what are they doing essentially
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on yeah probably
quite a cringy one because i've spent
lots of my commission and can't really
remember anything particular but
when i got a bonus was like quite early
on it's my sister's 18th birthday so
i've got like quite a nice holiday from
the whim what non-negotiation would you
live by each day that you feel has a
massive impact on your productivity and
helps you maximize these damn
recruitment yeah so always try and write
out like a clear day plan before i leave
and then just have a really clear to-do
list in that day and just try and make
sure i get everything done that list
last one how do you think we can change
the perception of the equipment
uh i think a bit of a plug here like
companies like sr2 like the whole like
people over profit shift trying to be a
good human i think just generally trying
to give back i think on linkedin and
seeing lots more companies
do that and give back to charity and i
think the more that we can kind of talk
about that and not just measure success
by actually like deals and and
everything else but measured by like the
difference we're making as well
[Music]